now when someone asks you if you are
subscribed to the new world review then
you have but one answer which repeat
after me
is yes i am
and if it's not true then well we need
to make it true right here and now hit
that magician's red button
and prepare to receive regular jojo
content upload it straight into your
youtube feed hello and welcome to the
new order of your source for everything
anime and manga and much more
importantly welcome to the stand
encyclopedia where today is time to
continue
our journey down the deep deep rabbit
hole that is jojo's bizarre adventure
and in this we find ourselves examining
the mighty magician's red magician's red
is a close-range natural humanoid stand
with primarily fire-based abilities
which takes the appearance of a wildly
stacked man
with a bird-like head or well i guess
it's not bird-like it's pretty
solidly just a bird head and this stand
is wielded by muhammad abdul during part
three of this grand saga stardust
crusaders and just on that the
commentary of magicians red as featured
in jojola actually sheds some light on
this design choice with hirohiro aki
stating i gave it a birdlike head
modelled after a phoenix
so the hero silhouettes wouldn't look
too similar to one another when they're
side by side it's pretty simple right
the design might have been influenced by
enki belov's characters now for some
context here enki bilal is a french
comic book artist as well as filmmaker
who created the nikopal trilogy which
featured the egyptian god horus the very
concept of which would go on to form
magicians red
in terms of its moveset and horus is of
course a commonly known deity who is
generally depicted as a man
with a falcon for a head or not a falcon
for a head with a head of a falcon if he
had a falcon for a head that would
that would look even stranger but i do
find it fascinating here that arky's
entire decision-making process
surrounding the creation of magician's
red was simply that he wanted an
incredibly distinct visual variance
between the stands of the main
characters and you know if magicians
read was simply another basic human guy
thing
then maybe yeah it could look a bit too
similar to star platinum and i have to
admit it certainly is effective and i
think you can see this very basic
concept of play with all of the stands
possessed by the main cast of part 3.
araki goes to great length to craft
distinct entities that could never be
mistaken for another whether it is
through color texture
size or even bird heads now in regards
to how it fits into part 3 as we know
the majority of stands featured in
stardust crusaders directly correlate to
tarot cards and in this case magicians
red evokes the major arcana the magician
although it is also known as the magus
or the juggler depending on your
particular deck
but basically the magician represents
divine imminence which very basically
broken down
alludes to the presence of a spiritual
essence within our ever-mundane reality
which actually pairs extraordinarily
well with abdul because of all the
crusaders he is probably the one who
embodies the greater concepts treasured
amongst humanity most you know he's an
extremely loyal mature
capable leader as well as an incredible
strategist and abdul just in general
tends to have things a bit more figured
out than everyone else
as such he certainly stands apart pun
not intended but i'll take it at least
to me as a more divine presence than the
other more heavily flawed members of the
band with that said i guess there was
that one time when abdul did piss into
that guy's mouth so look
nobody is perfect but avdor would
certainly be the closest thing we have
in part three that's not all though
because when used in divination the
magician signifies talent and potential
informing the target of said divination
that there are key choices to be made
for better or worse certainly worse if
you encounter the magician in reverse
but very importantly the magician is
often associated with beginnings which
makes an awful lot of sense because
magician's red was the very first dance
scene in its full glory in jojo's
bizarre adventure now as for what this
fire birdie can do
let's take a look at some stats and
initially the stand could seem
a bit underwhelming having scored a b in
power speed and durability whilst
attaining a c
in range and precision whilst invoking a
shameful d
in its developmental potential it's
fairly solid in general though i mean
it's not the paragon of perfection that
star platinum was but magician's red is
more than a passing grade we'll uh we'll
give it that
in regards to power there's nothing
really to be complaining about with a b
and magicians red has demonstrated some
pretty fearsome combative force
such as when it was able to shatter the
armor of another stand judgment with a
mere singular kick
and as much as i don't want to put too
much stock into letters judgment had a b
rating and durability so we are looking
pretty good for magicians right here
however unlike many of the other punch
ghosts magicians red primarily showcases
its power through projectile flame
attacks
a great example of which would be a
crossfire hurricane during which time a
stand is able to conjure a series of
flaming arcs to be fired at an enemy
with each resulting in some pretty damn
devastating damage upon impact however
this is far from a simple blunt big old
projectile because the stand is also
capable of adapting this technique to
cover a much larger area or deal with
copious amounts of opponents if need be
through the crossfire hurricane special
in vacation which does see magicians red
conjo and arc but then split it into
many many smaller arcs for a greater
area of effect style attack and also
just in case you're not familiar an arc
is an egyptian hieroglyphic
that is used to represent life and as
such the possession of one can be seen
as an extension of life or at the very
least that was the idea i don't actually
know how well that worked for the
ancient egyptians probably not great
since they're all dead but i do quite
like how it is incorporated into
magicians red
as a more offensive technique rather
than a preservation of life there's a
nice siren either this actually goes all
the way back to horus though because his
eyes were said to be made up of the
morning star and the evening star aka
the sun and the moon the morning star
representing power whilst the evening
star signified healing so in many ways
the super basic attack from magician's
red
actually perfectly encapsulates the idea
of horus by summoning that overwhelming
flame power
in the shape of the symbol of life very
classic archy thought given to this one
here in regards to speed magicians red
is also nothing to scoff at because
while it is certainly not touted to move
at the speed of light like say star
platinum it was more than capable of
facing off against paul nara's silver
chariot which was
granted an a ranking in the realm of
speed a lot of this was of course due to
avdor's more strategic use of magician's
red
in order to make up for the gap that did
exist but that does display that this
stand
does possess a fairly incredible amount
of speed for that to even be an option
meanwhile it's not the greatest strength
is that of durability magicians red can
take quite the beating but we should
start to delve into some negatives here
which do present themselves in the range
category magician's red is of course a
close range stand
very similar to that of star platinum it
has a very narrow effective range
although it should be noted that since
its attacks are primarily projectile
based then this is much less of an issue
magicians red can just stick with abdul
all day long and fire anks wildly at
whatever opponent we may have this does
however bring up the issue of precision
you may have noticed this by now but
this stand is not
at all designed for subtle attacks fire
is a very unruly substance after all and
avdol tends to command it to its full
destructive potential
meaning that magician's red is a very
all or nothing endeavor in fact even its
specialty attack crossfire hurricane
special is simply designed to increase
the area of damage caused
rather than provide any sort of handy
utility and that brings us to by far the
worst category of magicians red which is
a very sad d
in developmental potential which
essentially means that what we see
is what we get which isn't to say that
it's impossible to push magician spread
further because you know it's not an
e-ranking at least but we're certainly
not going to see something like
magicians red act 2 or magicians read
the world
with that in mind given its low
potential i actually think that avdol is
a fairly amazing wielder of this stand
because he has managed to conjure a neat
little set of powers one of which would
be the red rough rope which spawns
flames designed to restrain an opponent
rather than to burn or hurt them
although the idea is also that
eventually the flames will burn all of
the oxygen around the target and
potentially lead to their suffocation
yay but here is where we see avdol make
the absolute most of that c
in precision because this is some fairly
subtle control over magician's red
reducing the immediate impact of the
flames
as well as moulding them into a
particular sort of semi-permanent shape
and another fascinating use of the stand
by abdul would be the life detector
technique whereby magicians red can
produce a heat radar capable of
detecting movements breathing
and even stand energy which is pretty
insane although that one time it was put
to usables against an opponent who hard
counted it entirely by having access to
another dimension
some more fun facts about magicians red
while this stand itself appeared in the
time before they were widely named after
various pieces of popular music the
signature attack of magicians red being
crossed by a hurricane was taken from
the opening line of jump and jack flash
by the rolling stones
and interestingly but irrelevantly
enough both jumping jack flash and
rolling stones would go on to be future
stand names in part 6 and 5 respectively
for a bit of a bizarre design change
though
magicians red looked ever so slightly
different in the ova incarnation of
jojo's bizarre adventure
in which it sports feathers around its
wrists rather than bracelets
as well as feathers that sprout further
down its neck and i have no idea why
these changes were made but i suppose
someone really wanted to dive into that
whole bird motif although the beak is
also a bit shorter so
i don't know scratch that idea and for
an even more useless fact
originally magician's red was a barefoot
stand however after abdul's return into
the story after the whole
fake out death ordeal from their
non-magician's red was seen wearing
arabian shoes
so it looks like avdor was not the only
one who was busy shopping during their
absence in part three now as for my
personal thoughts on magicians red i'll
be real i was kind of underwhelmed by my
first experience of it when i was going
through stardust crusaders
although to be fair at the time i had no
idea what to expect i was still very
much in that hum on mindset and all of a
sudden there was a big
bird ghost thing but i did grow to enjoy
the stand quite a lot and very rapidly
as well
after the concept of stance in general
became much more familiar to me i do
wish that magicians red had gotten a bit
more time to shine in the series
i mean it's peak was probably when avdor
was facing off against polynomial and
silver chariot
but that was an incredibly early moment
in the series and after that almost
every time it was summoned it just felt
like going through the motions with it
although to be fair you could probably
say that about quite a few part three
stands
really magician's red in my mind suffers
from the simplicity of stardust
crusaders it was the very first stand
showcased at the very dawn of this
concept that would eventually spiral
into this endlessly fascinating group of
existences which do make magicians red
seem incredibly
underwhelming in comparison and in
retrospect i do wish that archie had
taken a bit more advantage of the horus
inspiration and maybe equipped magicians
red with some sort of degree of healing
like maybe some blue phoenix flames or
something just to give it a bit more
depth although that probably would have
seemed quite overpowered in part three
so
uh look i guess it's fine for what it is
but where does that leave us here today
well despite my personal feelings there
is no denying that this is a solid and
sturdy stand
if you are looking for a punch ghost and
star platinum is not available then this
is a great choice because it does come
with that degree of raw power
and mild utility but mild is better than
none
and there are some stands who have
absolutely none but yeah i would never
go so far as to call this stand
particularly
versatile it has a very straightforward
purpose which is to engage in
destructive based combat which i do have
to wonder how often abdul did prior to
the events part three
i mean before dio anya went wild with
the stand arrows stand users would have
been pretty damn read to stumble across
although i can't deny that being able to
instantly summon a firebird is a nice
piece of comfort to have in the back of
your mind
during any stage of life and with that i
think we can officially add magicians
red to the stand
encyclopedia but what do you guys think
of magicians red please do let me know
down in the comments below or even join
my discord server and if you're keen for
some more jojo content then please do go
and check out some of my other videos or
even subscribe to the channel the
regular jojo wonder delivered straight
into your youtube feed but for now this
has been the new world review
and i'll see you next time